What is a virus?
A virus is a teeny-tiny little particle, right?
That it's smaller than a bacteria.
We can't even see viruses with normal microscopes.
We have to use really really high power microscopes
to see them.
A pencil is like one millimeter in diameter.
You can fit almost a half a billion to a billion
different virus particles on
the tip of the pencil.
That is how small a virus is.
And, interestingly, viruses-- scientists have
been studying the natural history of viruses,
and they think that viruses actually came
into being, they started four billion
years ago, before any other type of life ever
was created.
So, four billion years is a really long time
to become a very perfect machine,
right?
And, so, I want to also tell you that there
are millions
and millions of different viruses all over
the planet, and most of these viruses do not
get us sick,
okay?
There is a virus for every type of cell.
There's tons of viruses
that get-- that go into bacteria.
There's viruses that go into plants.
There's viruses that go into all sorts of
animals.
But, for humans, we don't really get sick
by a lot of viruses.
There's a number of viruses that we have to
be careful about,
but overall viruses are actually not terribly
harmful for us when we look at the numbers,
right?
But, for the viruses that are harmful we do
have to think about things like vaccines
and other types of treatments and other types
of behaviors,
like the behavior were practicing now called
social distancing.